hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
trocken welt auch heute möchte ich euch
wieder einen kleinen snack zeigen den
ihr zu silvester zu bereiten könnte und
zwar mache ich heute tun fischbrötchen
das ist einfach so ein ganz cooler snack
dann machen wir auch ganz gerne auch mal
abends so zum essen und zwar ist es so
ein thunfisch aufstrich den man auch
solche aufbackbrötchen gibt und dann
kommen die anderen den ofen gebacken und
die brötchen kamera warm oder kalt essen
das heißt ihr könnt zum beispiel
entweder diese creme vorbereiten so ein
tag vorher oder morgens und dann abends
die brötchen damit bestreichen und
frische in den ofen schieben und heiß
essen oder ihr könnt eben schon die
brötchen fertig backen und das ganze
auch kalt essen also uns mit beides
sowohl kalt als auch warm und die zeigt
sich einfach mal was ihr an zutaten
benötigt und wie gesagt braucht ihr am
zutaten ein paar aufbackbrötchen ich hab
da ist eine packung da sind sechs stück
drin aber der aufstrich will auch für
märklin reichen
ich habe ich hier 200 gramm schmandt ihr
könnt aber auch sauer raum nehmen die
sich in etwa das gleiche
ihr braucht 200 gramm käse den habe ich
jetzt schon gegeben dass ich in gouda
und ich nehme auch ganz gern den gouda
am stück weil ich dann eben keine
trennmittel drin habe in diesen fertig
geriebenen käse dann braucht ihr eine
zwiebel eine kurze oder so wie bei mir
zwei kleine eine knoblauchzehe oder auch
mehr wenn ihr eben diesen geschmack
intensiver haben wollt dann nehme ich
eine große thunfisch die ist ohne öl die
hat nämlich den eigenen saft das heißt
das ganze etwas fett freier ich achte
darauf dass ich eine marke nehmen die
für nachhaltige fischerei steht und eben
keine delft
eine mit in meine hose sind dann braucht
ihr ein paar gewürze ich habe hier einen
halben teelöffel salz
hier habe ich etwas pfeffer und
cayennepfeffer verschärfe und hier ganz
wichtig finde ich oregano weil es das
ganze eben schön automatisch macht und
das ist hier natürlich nur so die
grundzutaten das heißt ihr könnt eben
stark schwankt auch so annehmen
ihr könnt auch mal mit quark probieren
das habe ich bisher noch nicht probiert
kann ich mir aber auch gut vorstellen
und statt dem gau da könnt ihr natürlich
jeden anderen käse nemo wie emmentaler
nehmt oder edamer oder diesen türkischen
käse kascha pingel
das geht alles ihr könnt alles
austauschen aber eben in der gleichen
menge und ich weiß jetzt einfach weil es
ganz schnell geht im thermomix machen
ihr könnt aber jeden anderen weg zu
nehmen das geht aber auch ganz gut ohne
[ __ ]
es geht natürlich jetzt einfach nur
darum dass ihr die zwiebeln klein da
kommt und die scheiße ich jetzt einfach
in den weg und wenn ihr keine messer
benutzen wollte dir einfach ganz klein
in feine würfel damit sich das einmal
auf 6 beim thermomix ist ab und zu etwas
blöd dann muss man das mit dem spatel
immer mal wieder unterschriften gerade
wenn man ganz wenig im mixed kopf hat
wenn man es dann nochmal macht ganz gut
leben sind sie mich auf den punkt und
geht aber vorher den saft ab hier ist
ziemlich viel saft drin wie es sehen
können dass die sich jetzt ab indem ich
den deckel drauf drücken und es dann ins
waschbecken abgeht und dann kommt es
einfach damit dazu also thunfisch
zu den zwiebeln käse und dann auch alle
anderen käse oder short und alle gewürze
und jetzt wird es eine ganz kunstvereins
und so sieht diese passte jetzt aus und
die könnte auch ganz gut abschmecken
jetzt und gucke neben ob ihr auch salz
oder verbraucht oder etwas schärfe und
diesen auch strich könnt ihr jetzt wie
gesagt auch in den kühlschrank geben und
so stehen lassen
aber ich zeige euch hier die größte
bestreicht und zwar müsst ihr die
brötchen einmal halbiert das machte am
besten so gut wie möglich und so gerade
wie möglich und ich nehme mir immer ganz
gern die kleinen ein bisschen es gibt ja
auch die größeren aber ich finde es mit
denen schöner und zum bestreichen dem
ich mir am liebsten seiner winkel
palette bei muss dann schön glatt
streichen kann und das ist halten essen
was man richtig gut vorbereiten kann ich
nur schneller küche so richtig fastfood
und kann man gut vorbereiten kann wenn
man berufstätig ist weil man dann auch
den dieb schon vorher also morgens oder
am abend vorher zubereiten kann
und wenn man nach hause kommt bestreitet
man den brötchen und schiebt sie in den
ofen und hatten richtig schnelles selbst
gemachtes essen und wenn ihr schnell
arbeitet seit er da wirklich in zehn
minuten mit dem aufstrich fertig mit dem
bestreichen und habe sie dann im ofen
für etwa 15 minuten und eine fertigpizza
auch nicht schneller gewachsen und so
wisst ihr was drinsteckt und wisst was
ihr ein gebt ihr könnt den geschmack
bestimmen und habe sie eben selbst
gemacht und ich habe auch echt noch
keine fertigen baguette brötchen
gegessen diese rot schmecken weil die
alle ziemlich fad schmecken ganz darauf
achten bestreicht die nicht zu dick wir
mögen sie am liebsten wenn sie so einen
halben zentimeter tricksen und dann legt
die brötchen jetzt gleichauf mein
backblech mit meiner back folie da läuft
ja auch nichts aus und ich stehe ja
nicht so viele putts
und dann kommen sie bei etwa 220 grad
für so etwa 15 minuten in den ofen
also bei mir brauchen selber 15 minuten
einfach bis sie schön goldbraun sind an
der oberfläche zu sehen jetzt meine
fertigen brötchen aus die sind richtig
schön goldbraun gebacken und richtig
lecker auch und ihr habt ja auch gesehen
das war wirklich sehr schnell gemacht in
zehn minuten waren die brötchen im ofen
15 minuten später waren sie auch schon
fertig und ihr könnt den thunfisch
natürlich auch austauschen
also ich esse auch ganz gerne mehr
zurück das ist so eine türkische
knoblauch wurst oder auch mit salami und
etwas kunden post ihr könnt aber auch
vegetarisch machen dann können paprika
eingeben und mais und shopping jungs
strikt alles richtig gut
hauptsache ihr habt diese basis aus
sauerrahm oder schmand und käse das ist
wirklich so die basis und da können sie
dann alles mögliche reinpacken
ich mache das auch manchmal ganz gerne
nur mit mais und habe ich so meine
brötchen und mit dem käthe könnte er
auch variieren dann könnte auch
verschiedene geschmäcker ausprobieren
das rezept gibt es natürlich auch zum
nachlesen auf www.starbett.de und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen
lasst mir einen kommentar mit euch
gefallen hat und teilt das video gern
mit euren freunden bis zum nächsten mal